data it's being created all the time
from devices applications and their
users because it's digital is measurable
but what about information offline in
the physical world
there's actionable offline data just
waiting to be discovered and with
devices that can capture convert and
send the newly discovered data
businesses companion industry can start
measuring their operations in real time
to anticipate events proactively and the
spot issues before they become problems
processing this data would be easy for a
few devices but what about hundreds
Allison or even millions Google cloud
platform offers powerful tools to
capture massive volumes of data
distributed around the world along with
an easy way to process the data whether
it's streaming real clients are tucked
away in your law queries instantly into
what - Tiffany can any part of your
business with easy-to-use big data tools
and zero infrastructure management so no
matter what your business is you can
analyze performance in all the places
that matter this is the Internet of
Things get started today and see how
Google cloud platforms can extend your
businesses into a connected world
[Music]